We built a society where we're told to
go to college, find someone we love,
work a job for 50 years and we're
going to live happily ever after.
But it doesn't happen,
but we don't necessarily feel it that
you guys actually set us up for success.
Can I have my millennials stand in the
right ball of light and my baby boomers
on the left tool at light
when it comes to jobs,
you should do what you want.
Love.
I'm going to say, hell yes. Do what
you love because if you don't love it,
you want to do a good job, then get quit
and bring a company down, et Cetera,
et cetera. I agree. I mean,
I tried to put myself in a position to
stay away from things that I don't like.
I hated to go into school,
so I left and I cannot tell
you how powerful that was.
I'm the CEO and founder of tens of tea.
I went to Ucla, hated going to school,
so I dropped out after three
years and became an entrepreneur.
It just occurred to me though.
I wonder if maybe we're all fortunate
enough that we can because not everybody
gets to just do what they love.
Maybe circumstances don't allow
that depending on, you know,
I'm just fortunate I was brought up
in a family that allowed me to explore
options and paid for me to go to college
and even though we all agree that you
should do what you love,
I agree with you completely
and it went through my mind,
but I think that it's important,
at least for me to say,
everyone should be able to do what they
love and to have that be an expectation
for everyone and not have it be an
expectation. Okay, well you know,
if you have challenges in your life,
then you'll never be
able to do what you love.
We had a Japanese restaurant
growing up and I cooked tempera,
you know,
did my homework and took naps on the
stocks of bags of rice that we had in the
back. Did I love it? No, but we did
it because it was part of survival.
I did computer science and I was a program
or for 10 years before I decided to
pursue what I really love,
which was music. So Dede,
I don't agree with that statement.
Do you love all the jobs and I'm
sure your goal to do what you love,
don't you think like whatever. It might
have to take steps to get to that,
but that's what I worry about if
we're going to talk about generational
differences.
I own a couple of businesses in Missouri
and I think sometimes the younger
generation doesn't get that part,
that just be to do what you love.
Sometimes you have to do
some things you hate to get
fair.
Millennials don't work as
hard as previous generations.
Yes,
I live in southern Missouri and I
own a couple of businesses there.
So I do think when I'm in La
I notice a big difference.
So I think part of it is a
geographic thing. You know,
I live in a small town in the
middle of nowhere where you know,
people don't have role models necessarily
that or to look up to that are,
are as motivated. And it's also really
easy to get free stuff. You know,
low income housing, food stamps and
disability. Or they'll come to me and say,
well, I can only work 25 hours a week
because if I work more than that,
I'm going to lose my low income housing.
Like I said,
I think that's partly the society where
I live makes it too easy not to work.
I think a baby boomer is somebody who
was taught to work hard and that if you
want something, you have to figure
out how to go out and get it.
And don't wait for somebody to hand it
to you. If you try hard enough, you can.
You can get about anything you want.
Oh,
I wasn't talking about you guys.
So it all depends on who you know
and who you run into around me.
There's sure a lot of millennials
that are working hard.
I know I hear stories
about others who are lazy,
but isn't that the truth
in any generation? Yes.
I work with a younger generation
all the time. And so I,
I mean they come in 24 seven you know,
they're working very,
very hard and I couldn't work
without the younger generation.
I wouldn't want to work that.
The younger generation,
I think millennials work harder than
previous generations for less safety net
and less structural stability.
And I think you see people who maybe
they're not trying to go to work as hard
because they know that if they try and
they lose whatever assistance they have
or if they tried to go to school and
they get in debt and they can ever pay it
out or know that they can never live
in a place other than that low income
housing unit,
then there's like a lack of agency
maybe to try but also so many forces.
And then you know,
you have all these companies that are
trying to get leaner and deliver on short
term profits.
So they hire people as contractors.
Like all my friends are contractors
and they don't have health insurance,
they don't have any of these other things.
And then so like they've
got to work harder.
So I guess when I hear
that about millennials,
it makes me upset just because I
know how hard my friends are working.
I think the word millennial is often
use to portray a small slice of
millennials. I don't quite
fit some of those stereotypes,
but I don't think there's
a single stereotype either
young people today face harder
challenges than any previous generation.
Oh yeah.
I'm actually gonna to disagree.
Okay.
Oh cool.
Can't wait to get that.
I think the biggest challenge
facing young people days,
the environment and that we're growing
up in a world that is not being taken
care of and what that means for, you know,
me and my children, if I have children,
what type of world they're
going to be living in.
And I just think it's not
something we're addressing at all.
I think the social media, it, like
I said, it can be a great tool,
but I also think it can make life
more difficult for people. Um,
because you can get offended or
bullied or relationships can be totally
different now because of,
you know,
people break up with you
over a text or whatever.
And I think that's adds benefits,
challenges to that we didn't have
as an adult.
Um,
I find it hard to compare it to my mother
and her generation when it comes to
meet you and to buy a house. So when
it comes to me trying to save money,
because I am one of those contract
workers and I do want a family and so is,
do I continue doing what I love?
I do.
I did go back into the though rat race
and try to get ahead and try to do Xyz.
That's the pressure that I
face on a day to day. Right.
Companies that hired you for life and
you have tension, you had good to let,
you know, that's all
gone. All gone understand.
The cost of living is so high. Or if
you live in a place where it's not high,
then there were no jobs. You know,
I think it's harder for you guys.
Okay.
It's good to hear all your points.
Um,
I still think that we
actually have it a lot easier.
Um, and I think the problem is
that we expect too much. Um,
I don't think that we should deserve
to assume that we're going to get to
immediately be able to afford a house.
And I think that we have a
lot of things going for us.
And I learned a lot of really
valuable skills completely for free.
You can join Facebook groups
and meet other entrepreneurs.
It doesn't cost any money.
You can literally take classes at MIT
and Harvard for free classes online
and you guys didn't have that
access to information was in there.
I totally get the financial
and environmental challenges.
So I think that we have the
resources to kind of solve them.
It's important to, you know, want to be a,
have leave each generation
better than we found it. Um,
because if we lose sight of that, then
you know, what are we working for?
My children will grow up in
a better world than I did
shit. Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Because I'll make sure that
I think absolutely. Yeah,
absolutely.
For me.
I am determined when I do start,
my family did that they will have
a better life than what I've had.
I'm going to make sure as a father,
as a provider did that pastor
happened period point blank.
I don't have children but I'm speaking
for children in general is even though I
first said life is harder
for a younger generation,
I think you're right and you know
healthcare is getting so much better,
so much faster and then the Internet has
made so many more things possible that
I do think that young people will grow up
in an easier world overall then we did.
I definitely agree with the personal
sentiment that we all share, but I do,
I do like think that one of the things
we didn't really have to talk about was
that like we don't
necessarily feel that the,
you guys actually set us up for success.
Like essentially we built a society
where we're told to go to college,
find someone we love and go buy a house
and work a job for 50 years and we're
going to live happily ever after.
But it doesn't happen.
I just don't get like how do you guys
assumed that we were going to be able to
do that exact same thing?
No, no. We'll all I know
I don't assume that,
but what I do is that I put the work
in so when you put the work in and, and
maybe not you per se,
but the larger mindset of the
boomers is necessarily, you know,
you guys are working like I did
and you guys be okay. Like, Nah.
I think the expectations are changing.
Like I,
everything you said about the
house in the marriage, you know,
I mean in my generation and that
was my job as a female wisdom.
Catch your husband.
That's right. That's why we went to
college. That's why women went to cut.
That's when my Mrs Degree College,
your generation has so many more
opportunities in a wider vision of what
happiness can look like and that it
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
live in a house with a picket fence and
you're going to have 2.2 kids and you're
going to stay in the same job forever.
I mean,
I think you have so many more
options available to you.
Some of that has shifted for you.
So I hope at least it has.
I think that's what I love about the
younger generation now is that they're
working on themselves first as opposed
to falling in love and you know,
getting it right.
That's going to be all well and good.
But I think what we're saying is we've
been sewed up a creek without a paddle.
Okay,
well I'm a mom so I'm looking at
the future and I feel for you guys,
you know who you're working hard,
which is great,
but everything is getting more
expensive on the environment. Yes,
that is a concern.
But one of the things that really
concerns me is a national debt and we're
borrowing and borrowing from the future
or kicking the can down the road,
letting you guys and your kids and your
grandkids take care of it. So I, you know,
I, on behalf of our generation,
at least on that aspect of life,
we're really sorry we're,
we are,
we're leaving a big mess for you guys
and I just pray for you guys pretty far.
Children, I am hopeful to.
I'm optimistic for our kids,
but I'm also well aware of some troubles
that we're leaving our next generation.
Yeah, but I will tell you this, you
will survive. I don't want to survive.
You will
survive you all three of it.
You can't be entitled to anything.
I'm entitled.
We want what we want. The what
was, what did the new deal.
There wasn't a cell for. We want
that too. That's all we're saying.
We want the basics of the American
dream period. There you go.
All right.
That's all the time.
Hey guys,
what's up?
My Name's Dan and I'm Jason and thank
you so much for watching our episode.
We'd love to know what you
think in the comments. Also,
let us know in the comments below what
other episodes you guys want to see from
middle ground. We love hearing from you
guys. Hit subscribe, watch more videos.
Get your next.